[Musik]
dollar
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wenn man immer auf der reise ist es ist
sehr wichtig dass wir gut arbeiten
das spektiv dass man ein
unterwegs auf rund und auch wieder
bretter
gerade kommen
wir fliegen nach mogadischu eine der
gefährlichsten städte der welt
der somalische flüchtling hassan will
beweisen dass es sich lohnt dort zu
investieren ist dies der helle wahl oder
hat seine idee chancen davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
baden an einem augusttag der
bürgermeister von mogadischu wird zu
besuch erwartet der it-spezialist hasan
sis man hat diesen anlass mit
organisiert er ist einer von 7.000
somalis die in der schweiz leben betreue
und ganze programm mitgestalten
eingeladen hat stadtammann geri müller
allerdings als privatperson müller hat
mogadischu 2014 besucht heute
revanchierte sich mit einer einladung
nach baden in der schweiz ist somalia
als hort des terrorismus bekannt umso
wichtiger ist es für hassan dass die
beziehung zwischen seiner heimat und der
schweiz auf allen ebenen aufgenommen und
gepflegt werden
ja das wird schön guess engagement ich
bin zu malen und gerade gut und lager in
die mitmenschen normalität gefunden
wichtig ist auch mit niemand meldet dass
die heat verloren
wichtigste ist dass die diaspora
somalische haben sich für das eigene
land sind sicherlich setzen denn wir
natürlich irgendwelche know-how vordach
und mit nähe und ausland durch bauer für
einen bürgermeister aus dessen stadt die
menschen in den westen geflohen sind ist
ein exil somalia wie hassan ein traum
sozusagen eine kostenlose werbetrommel
nach baden kam ich um den bürgermeister
persönlich kennenzulernen
mogadischu habe ich bereits einmal
besucht und ich weiß wie gefährlich es
dort ist vom bürgermeister erhoffe ich
mir unterstützung für unsere geplante
reise
die begegnung zwischen den zwei männern
endet mit einem symbolischen geschenk
einer dvd und einem honig aus der region
hassan hat guten grund zufrieden zu sein
der bürgermeister sagte ihm bereits zu
uns punkto sicherheit in mogadischu zu
unterstützen
somit ist dieser besuch zumindest für
unser vorhaben ein erfolg dass andere
zieht also vor modischer zeige wenn nur
das negative wo ihr werdet sondern auch
das positive hochform obergeschoss einen
monat später kurz vor der landung in
mogadischu 2012 wartete die uno auf mich
ist der bürgermeister auch so
zuverlässig meine haare sind bereits
bedeckt somalia ist ein islamisches land
wo sich die frauen verhüllen
der bürgermeister hat sein versprechen
eingehalten
auf uns wartet ein gepanzerter allrad
worden
die truppen der afrikanischen union
sichern bis heute das gebiet um den
flughafen
die islamistische terrorbewegung
al-shabaab wurde 2011 aus mogadischu
verjagt doch bombenanschläge gibt es
immer noch unser fahrer ist im
funkkontakt mit dem bewaffneten
begleitpersonal besucher aus europa
können sich ohne diesen schutz nicht in
der stadt bewegen
auch alle die für die regierung arbeiten
und somit für eine stabilisierung des
landes sind den islamistischen
fanatikern ein dorn im auge ein thema
worüber hassan ungern spricht
es ist ja also selbstverständlich ist es
geht ihr also es ist nicht normal wenn
das in wiso personal täglich nach
modischer roth
wir sind unterwegs zum sitz der
stadtregierung
entlang dieser straße sieht es alles
andere als nach wirtschaftlichem
aufschwung aus im gegenteil
hier springen einem die zerstörungen des
25 jährigen bürgerkriegs geradezu ins
auge
das rathaus von mogadischu hingegen
überrascht 2012 war es noch eine ruine
von flüchtlingen bewohnt heute gilt es
als symbol für die wiederauferstehung
der stadt und für die rückkehr
politischer strukturen passen will der
bürgermeister seine aufwartung machen
diese ist jedoch auf pilgerfahrt und
sein stellvertreter befindet sich in
einer sitzung im rathaus sind vor jedem
büro soldaten stationiert ohne sie
würden viele politiker nicht mehr leben
dennoch bieten viele der somalia die
bereits aus dem exil zurückgekehrt sind
ihre dienste der stadtverwaltung an
hier setzten sie ihr im ausland
erworbenes know how ein
auch unser begleiter ahmad seinen gut
bezahlten job in indien aufgegeben um
für den wiederaufbau der stadt zu
arbeiten
viele somalia kehren aus dem exil zurück
und investieren in somalia sei es in
kleinunternehmen oder in immobilien
das rathaus ist für hassan weit mehr als
eine drehscheibe der politik agiere
frauen da im hauptstadt für den
bürgermeister will ohne kontakt so der
bürgermeister
schließlich gewährt und der
stellvertreter eine audienz ausgetauscht
werden vor allem höflichkeitsfloskeln
doch die sind in dieser kultur von
enormer bedeutung der stellvertreter
versichert und seiner unterstützung bei
der erkundigung der stadt die
politischen rituale zwischen baden und
mogadischu unterscheiden sich kaum
gruppenfotos gehören an beiden orten
dazu
frei fühle ich mich in mogadischu nur
auf dem hoteldach es ist der einzige ort
wo mir kein soldat über die schulter
geguckt als erste europäische
fluggesellschaft fliegt wirklich
airlines heute täglich nach mogadischu
lange zeit landeten hier nur flugzeuge
aus afrika die wirtschaft ist erstmals
wieder am wachsen
es wurden zahlreiche hotels und
wohnblöcke gebaut
[Musik]
die aussicht vom hoteldach begeistert
auch hassern ein freund zeigt ihm was
sich in der stadt getan hat
moretti schule galt einst als perle am
indischen ozean ist überzeugt dass seine
heimatstadt diesen ruf wiedererlangen
wird und wo jetzt ist bei broker hat und
jetzt braucht der applikation dass sich
jetzt wieder tut wieder erhole
und wenn man das prinzip gibt zu wasser
dann ist die chance groß dass eine rede
vor dem kind kann auch später etwas
profitieren kann
um den fortschritt in der stadt zu
verstehen hilft ein blick zurück noch
2012 konnte ich mich nur in einem ihnen
sicheren panzer bewegen kugelsichere
westen und helmen barren vorschrift
mogadischu war ein einziges
flüchtlingslager mit menschen kann ich
kaum in kontakt
[Musik]
bei jedem halt sorgten die soldaten der
afrikanischen union für einen
sicherheitsabstand
ohne schutz geht es auch heute nicht
doch es ist das erste mal dass ich ein
denkmal wie dieses mahnmal für die
kriegsgefangenen besuchen darf noch mehr
als der opa lisk interessiert mich das
leben rund herum
es ist in der regel unmöglich das
alltagsleben ohne eine autoscheibe vor
der linse filmen zu können
in diesem quartier werden die ruinen
bewusst stehen gelassen
sie sollen für immer an das elend des
krieges erinnern
der anblick stimmt mich nachdenklich was
geht wohl in hassan vor und es tut mir
vorher zu werden hier kreuzt sehr
gestört sind
es tut mir von herzen weh dass die
wirtin armut lambert aber dass in
somalia in die nächste jahr mehr als 15
minuten dürfen wir uns hier nicht
aufhalten
es könnte gefährlich werden wenn sich
unsere anwesenheit herumspricht
wir waren lange genug hier
wir müssen gehen und zwar jetzt
[Musik]
mogadischus gefahren vergisst man vor
allem an einem ort am stadtstrand
[Musik]
bis vor kurzem waren hier nur fischer
anzutreffen
heute wimmelt es von badegästen gut
gesichert von wachposten hassan hat eine
überraschung für mich bereit wir
besuchen eine der akrobatischen
darbietungen die am wochenende
vorgeführt werden
solch geballte lebensfreude habe ich
hier noch nie gesehen
[Applaus]
mit ihrer darbietung treffen die drei
männer den richtigen nerv in dem sie
kriegerische handlungen in einem
kunstvollen slapstick verwandeln helfen
sie den menschen für kurze zeit dem
immer noch schwierigen alltag zu
entfliehen
[Applaus]
die somalische flagge geschmückt
sämtliche boote hassan lädt mich auf
eine zehnminütige spritztour ein
[Musik]
zum ersten mal seit unserer ankunft
wirkt er richtig entspannt im wasser
lauern keine selbstmordattentäter der
ständige druck für meine sicherheit zu
sorgen entfällt dass wir auch hier
beschützt werden ist eher symbolischer
natur piraten gibt es seit längerem
keine mehr als jugendleiter system bin
ich aufgewachsen haben ein bisschen tag
sehen dass der bund wenn besuch da fühle
ich mich wohler da hat das kann das ist
meine heimat
diese große liebe zu seinem land ist
letztlich hats als triebfeder um hier
etwas aufzubauen
boasson der normalität entstehen auch
mitten in der stadt
der spielplatz ist teil des sogenannten
friedenspark der park besteht vor allem
aus einer grünfläche mit einigen
sitzgelegenheiten doch in mogadischu ist
dies der einzige ort wo man spazieren
kann
das macht ihn zum beliebtesten fotosujet
der stadt unter all den männern fällt
mir eine frau auf die 16-jährige aus
london
als ich zum ersten mal hierher kam gab
es keine straßen oder sie waren holprig
heute gibt der straßen bildung es gibt
viel gutes siehst du deine zukunft in
somalia
in einigen jahren wird man hier eine
enorme verbesserung sehen
ich bin sicher dass viele somalia
zurückkehren werden viele sind schon
letztes jahr gekommen
hasan ist mit seiner familie bereits als
siebenjähriger in die schweiz geflüchtet
doch richtig glücklich wird auch er sich
nur hier
ihre heimat immer vermisst zumal obwohl
ich in der schweiz bin aber heimatland
im moment wohnt kann man nicht
vergleichen land blieb immer von herzen
für den it spezialisten findet der
wichtigste moment unserer reise in
unserem hotel statt er kann endlich den
besitzer eines großen
telekommunikationsunternehmens treffen
dieser kehrte bereits 2006 aus
deutschland nach somalia zurück
[Musik]
im gespräch tasten sich die beiden
männer ab was hätte das anzubieten was
könnte den geschäftsmann interessieren
letztlich sucht hasan in mogadischu ein
unternehmen mit ausbaumöglichkeiten
geschäftstätigkeit
man muss es in ein freundliches setzen
er kann mit keinem anfangen aber auch
mit bussen
wichtig ist dass man hier etwas machen
hin
aber er hat auch diese himmel
ich kann
das schon ahnen ja das ist genau so wie
es mir auch damals ging
ob es zu einer zusammenarbeit kommt wird
sich zeigen
hast du nutzt dennoch die gelegenheit
für einen aufruf an potenzielle
investoren
sie weiß jetzt befolgt hat sich jetzt
die kommentare ins normale investiere
telekommunikation und infrastruktur also
risk no fun
es gibt sicherheitsgarantie
also wer jetzt in afrika vor allem in
afrika investiert davor haben nach drei
tagen muss ich mich von mogadischu
verabschieden dass es hier
investitionsmöglichkeiten gibt habe ich
gesehen doch wenig hassan auch in seiner
zweiten heimat der schweiz besuchen um
ihn besser zu verstehen
im spätherbst treffe ich ihn an seinem
arbeitsplatz hasan ist beim
telekommunikationsanbieter jps cablecom
angestellt er hat sich zum technischen
berater hoch gearbeitet hier lernte er
auch wie die schweizer im allgemeinen
ticken bekannte pünktlichkeit
abmachungen oder grafiker warten wir ab
macht im schnitt und wo der schweiz
lernt man wirklich dass man bodenständig
auris und sogar gegenüber partners
während kleinsteuber einer der drei
geschäftsführer von uk com ist von
hassan begeistert ja er wäre beinahe
selbst mit uns nach mogadischu gekommen
hassan hat ihn vor einigen monaten
gefragt ob er als privatperson
interessiert wäre in somalia im bereich
der telekommunikation zu investieren
heute berichtet er ihm kurz von unserer
reise also zunächst mal überraschend das
ist ja keine idee mit der man jeden tag
konfrontiert wird
aber wir haben darüber gesprochen und es
ist natürlich eine ganz spannende
situation also wirtschaftlich sicherlich
auf lange frist interessant man hat
natürlich und muss natürlich auch sehr
viele bedenken haben und fragen abklären
aber er hat zumindest mal sehr
substanzielle erste antworten gegeben
und
die diskussion an seiner hartnäckigkeit
und zielstrebigkeit feilt hassern auch
in seiner freizeit
er ist ein leidenschaftlicher
billardspieler
es scheint dass sie nichts bremsen kann
wenn du meinst das alles viel länger du
hast du meine geschäft heißt das kalte
buffet und bis heute unbedingt weg aber
wenn das passiert also will am putin
schlug ihr wenn sie schon ein kataster
wird damit sie gar nicht passieren für
eine art bremse
ich bin da in der schweiz mit nun wissen
mit nun know how und das was ich jetzt
erreicht das schätze ich sehr
was ich der schweiz gelernt hat und wie
vorwärts ich bin und mit know-how und
die möglichkeit und beziehe gewesen
während ich sicher nicht wie bereits
schon immer von editions rettern in den
nächsten fünf jahre im sala terrena so
will und er sein ziel erreichen wird
oder nicht ist letztlich nebensache
vorbild für andere exil somalia ist er
allemal
[Musik]
nachtrag einen tag nach meinem besuch
explodierte vor dem präsidentenpalast
eine autobombe
es gab fünf tote sechs wochen später
starben bei einem anschlag auf ein hotel
15 menschen
der bürgermeister von mogadischu wurde
mittlerweile abgesetzt